problema número 24 una cuerda de 45
metros de largo está cortada en dos si
una pieza es 18 metros más grande que la
otra cual es la longitud en metros de la
pieza más pequeña tengo aquí mi cuerda
voy a dibujar la más o menos así esta es
mi cuerda y me dicen que esta partida en
dos
si este pedazo mide x metros este otro
pedazo mide x mas 18 metros ya que es 18
metros más grande que la primera y nos
dicen que las piezas combinadas miden 45
metros así que x + x + 18
es igual a 45
bueno vamos a resolver esto y éste sin
conoce pintó aquí están
aquí nos queda 2 x + 18 45 restamos 18
en ambos lados 2x es igual a 45 menos 18
2x es igual a 22 dividimos todo entre 2
x es igual a 22 entre 2 es igual a 11
esta es nuestra respuesta x el pedazo
más pequeño mide 11 metros veamos el
siguiente problema problema número 25 la
tierra viaja alrededor del sol a una
velocidad de aproximadamente 18 puntos 5
millas por segundo cuál será la
velocidad en millas por hora muy bien
veamos cuántos segundos hay en una hora
aunque tenemos que hay 60 segundos en un
minuto
y además hay 60 minutos
en una hora
esto es igual a estos minutos con
minutos se van 60 por 60 son 3600
segundos en una hora así que 18 puntos 5
millas por segundo lo multiplicamos por
esto esto por 18 puntos 5 millas
por segundo y esto es igual veamos ok
para hacer la multiplicación más rápida
voy a quitar estos dos ceros y voy a
hacer la multiplicación así 18.5 por 36
6 x 5 33 6 por 8 48 3 51
llevo 5
6 por unas 6 5 11 3 por 5 15 lleva 18
por 324 y 125 llevo 23 por 13 25 sumó
estos 0 6 6 6 aquí el punto decimal va
hacia acá un lugar
pero habíamos quitado dos ceros así que
a esto le agregamos dos ceros van a ser
66 600 66.600 el resultado de la
multiplicación 66.600 los segundos aquí
se van millas por hora
millas
por ahora
es nuestra opción de siguiente problema
si el cociente entre b es positivo cuál
de los siguientes enunciados es
verdadero bueno veamos nos dicen que a /
b es mayor a 0 es positivo esta licencia
no dice que tanto a como b son positivos
o ambos negativos entonces son ambos
positivos
a ambos
nativos
para que el resultado sea positivo si
fueran de diferente signo resultaría en
una fracción menor a 0
el enunciado nos dice que es mayor a 0
esto no necesariamente cierto pues ambos
pueden ser menores que ser ok la opción
b nos dice que es mayor a 0 y aquí
aplica lo mismo la opción c nos dice que
a x b es mayor a 0 y bueno ya dijimos
que hay b deben tener el mismo signo y
si los multiplico siempre dará un número
positivo positivo por positivo es
positivo negativo por negativo es
positivo así que esta es la opción
correcta la opción c veamos el problema
número 27
los puntos en la siguiente gráfica
indican el peso y eficiencia de uso de
combustible en 20 autos cuántos de ellos
pesan más de 2500 kilos y también tienen
una eficiencia de 22 kilómetros por
litro lo que nos piden entonces que
pesen más de 25 kilos 25 kilos pero más
no igual no significa que sea igual a 25
sino mayor que así que vamos a tomar en
cuenta aquellos que aparezcan
a partir de esta línea más o menos que
está por encima del 25 y que estén que
tienen una eficiencia mayor a 22
kilómetros por litro así que lo mismo no
este 22 kilómetros no se incluye este 22
kilómetros por litro no se incluye tiene
que ser mayor entonces vamos a poner la
línea que nos interesa acá quiere decir
que nos van a interesar puntos que se
encuentren acá en esta zona ya que son
los que cumplen que tienen una
eficiencia mayor mayor a estos 22
kilómetros por litro y pesan más
2500 kilos entonces esto es lo que nos
interesa y vemos que tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
son cinco puntos que nos interesan y la
respuesta de esto es ve vaya
muy bien vamos muy bien siguiente
problema problema número 28 cuántos
minutos tarda juan en escribir palabras
si él escribe a una velocidad de equis
palabras por minuto
ese es un problema bastante directo
aunque esto de las xy las 10 puede
confundir muchas gracias es mejor
sustituir estoy usar números nos dicen
cuántos minutos tarda juan en escribir
de palabras
y palabras
cuando él escribe una velocidad de equis
palabras
minuto
vemos que no se escribe 100 palabras
y su velocidad es de 50 palabras por
minuto
50 palabras por minuto
cuando tardó en escribir 100 palabras
pues dos minutos como supuesto puedes
dividiendo 100 entre 50 regresando a
estas variables
la respuesta aquí va a ser
/ x y esa es la opción yo creo que aquí
hay otro error porque es un problema
realmente muy sencillo y la respuesta
que tengo aquí en la copia de la prueba
es x entre ella y creo que esto es un
error de dedo yo sigo firme con mi
respuesta y la respuesta es entre x
bueno veamos el siguiente problema el
número 29
raíz cuadrada de 16 x 20 + 8 x 32 hay
varias formas de resolver esto pero la
más fácil es comenzar haciendo las
multiplicaciones y de aquí puedo
factorizar el 16 de ambos términos
aunque ustedes pueden hacer la
multiplicación y las operaciones para
encontrar el resultado creo que lo que
yo voy a hacer es un poquito más rápido
y aquí es importante la velocidad ok
entonces factor hizo el 16 raíz cuadrada
de 16 por 20 más
ok 32 16 por 2 así que esto es 8 por 2
esto es lo mismo que decir así que esto
es igual que tener raíz cuadrada de 16
por 20 más 8 por 2 16
esto es lo mismo que tener raíz cuadrada
de 16 por raíz cuadrada de 2016
hago esto porque puede ser complicado
resolverlo sin calculadora ok esto es
más menos 4 aunque viene las respuestas
todas son positivas así que esto es 4
por raíz cuadrada de 36 y 6 por 6 36 4
por 6 es igual a 24 que es nuestra
opción b